la deforestación de la cuenca de la
bahía de parita y una acelerada
acumulación de sedimentos han amenazado
a la población del retén ubicada en el
pacífico panameño césar y su familia han
sido víctimas de la crisis climática el
oleaje y el aumento del nivel del mar
han acabado de a poco con su hogar se
pusieron las llantas estas grandes y que
sin duda juntas
y sé de sembró los para nuestro de
mangle color agua y para ver si eran
resultados y a la vez a la vista se ve
que se está dando el resultado con esos
palos están haciendo bonito pero a la
gente es tan inhumana que los ácaros
corta a más de 100 kilómetros de
distancia y un cementerio de mangles que
terminarán convertidos en carbón esta
práctica es el sustento de jose y casi
100 familias que por décadas sólo han
conocido este oficio como forma de vida
mire yo de sincero mire yo tengo 61 años
que plan yo puedo está ya pensando
ya yo estoy ahora mismo que ya ni puedo
ni trabaja ya casi en 1970 los manglares
ocupaban cerca de 360 mil hectáreas en
la actualidad sólo ocupan 165 mil el
biólogo osvaldo jordán explica la
importancia de protegerlos es muy
importante para la mitigación y la
adaptación al cambio climático mitigan
el cambio climático porque almacenan una
gran cantidad de carbono en sus hojas en
sus troncos en sus raíces y también
contribuyen a la adaptación porque
representan una barrera protectora para
las comunidades humanas para evitar
afectaciones debido a las marejadas y
también los vientos que vienen desde los
océanos mientras césar e intenta
revertir la pérdida de manglares frente
a la costa el gobierno trabaja en un
proyecto que permitirá dar incentivos
económicos por la conservación de estos
bosques a través de un mercado nacional
de valores de bonos de carbono